des étoiles lointains cela voulait être
les premiers à toucher l'indemnité
billets collector distribuer à la poste
du louvre pour les moins rapides il est
des plus classiques les distributeurs
automatiques ont été pris d'assaut
vim tu vois ça fera un beau gentil chien
mais je pusse ému par la perte du franc
de laurent jahier voir avec moi j'ai
profité londonien depuis la première
fois son nom
molik d'aqaba à minuit mais d euros ce
serveur n'enverra que dans l'est pour
moi dans ce restaurant parisien
impossible hier de payer avec des
espèces en euro le franc a bénéficié
d'un sursis le temps du délai cela prête
les tracassent pc pour demain étonnant
s'occupera nous l'aurons du change de la
conversion et ce soir c'est la pète ya
les taxis ou s'ils ont été prêtés à la
monnaie n'est pas pourtant euros avec un
sourire ils vont payer ya pas de
problème
y'a pas de problème
les copies des cop est peut-être pas
mais dans ce kiosque ouvert toute la
nuit
les premiers ouvrages sont bien sortis
les porte monnaie des porte-monnaie de
touristes en tout cas
il a apporté d euros d'allemagne on a eu
les premiers centres et après ce
réveillon monétaire l'euro pourrait
peut-être même influencé aux cartes de
voeux je vous dis bonne année avec ce
roman euros à 10 euros